uh hearty welcome from the berlin
science week ladies and gentlemen and
welcome to everybody here in the room
and welcome to everybody following us
via live stream
i'm felix i'm going to be your presenter
your host for the next one and a half
hour here on this panel ladies and
gentlemen and um brought to you by 3m
germany and we raised a very important
question today it's not the science type
and we also already provide in the
beginning an answer to that question
with which is
so what i mean is there any specific
science type if you think of a scientist
i you probably imagine a male scientist
like albert einstein or maybe
like thomas edison or maybe sheldon
cooper whatever but do you also think of
marie curie or maybe another woman if
you're a fan of special knowledge like
nerdy knowledge maybe you know taputi
she was born 1200 bc and she was the
first ever recorded chemist in the whole
history
but still if you google
the most important chemists in in
history today you really have to search
hard for more women on that list but
because because of the put you could say
basically the chemistry was invented by
women so we really have to change this
kind of issue the question is how do we
do that we need more women in science we
need more career paths in science for
young women and for girls this has to
start already in the educational area in
the schools and when when there is this
moment when you when you really decide
where to go with your life and what
career path you want to take in
preparation for that event ladies and
gentlemen i
went back to the moment when i made that
decision i'm not a scientist i'm a tv
journalist i studied journalism and when
i thought about that moment my suddenly
there was a person popping up in my mind
which was my grandmother she was a very
funny lady and
and she got stuck in my brain with two
sentences the one thing has nothing to
do with the topic we are discussing
today but i tell you anyway
this is every time in our family
somebody made a dirty joke which from
time to time happened
she sat there and she had this very
intense look and she looked at this
person she was like
you do know
that only the hungry speak of the bread
right
and the second thing she always said to
me and this was a moment i really really
remember very well i was like 12 or 14
years old
and suddenly out of nothing she sat
there and she was like
felix i really envy your generation for
all the possibilities you got i was like
come on grandma this is progress of
course we have more possibilities than
you and when the moment came and i had
to decide for my career
i really was overwhelmed i had no clue
to what to do with my life and i felt
that i was standing on a corridor and
there were these endless doors and
within my possibilities i could enter
some of them but i didn't know which to
enter and the question was can i just
peek in there and go back on the and
take another take another door and so
this decision is very hard to make and
that's why we are here today if you are
searching for a career path in science
we want to provide you information but
also inspiration today and that's why we
have this panel
where i'm going to discuss with three
young female scientists and they're
going to tell us how they made their way
into science but before that we have
also another inspirational part we
brought a movie for years for you it's a
documentary about also four female and
very inspiring young scientists and when
they started their career they they i
think they wouldn't consider themselves
being the very typical science type but
when they started their career suddenly
they faced discrimination because of
race because of their gender because of
age
but it went fine for them and now they
really try to empower all the other
women in the world and all the girls in
the world to also go for that science to
to they are the ambassadors of a more
inclusive science and i would say we
have a look at this movie have fun see
you in a few minutes
[Music]
[Music]
i love doing a lot of different things
um one of my favorite things to do in my
free time is bake
but i don't know i'm not really good at
it but that's okay
i also fly
gliders dance indian classical
i also love playing the piano
i think that's pretty good oh fencing
finished it that time
my name is catanjuli rau
i'm 15 years old and i'm an innovator
scientist and promoter of stem
i won the 3m young scientist challenge
and i'm times kid of the year
i am a south asian girl
and you don't really see a lot of
females let alone females of color in
the field
and that became very frustrating and
very
isolating
just that idea of there's nobody else
that looks like me
a lot of times i'm overlooked for my
capabilities or i feel undermined
just because
people don't view me as a scientist or
an innovator
people don't think my ideas are valid
just because of how i look
and that's not right
this stereotype shouldn't even exist in
the first place
we have created this bias standard of
what a scientist is
and i'm hoping to really flip that
script and change that
a scientist is anybody and it shouldn't
be based on age race or gender
today it should be based on our
capabilities and our drive and
motivation to tackle world problems
apply that to the real world so how can
we use science and tech as a catalyst
for social change
my uncle got me the science kit when i
was four years old for my birthday or
christmas
i can tell you that that is not what i
wanted for that birthday i wanted a
barbie dream house and i never ended up
getting it and i'm very fortunate for
that
i think this science kit allowed me to
discover this knack that i had to solve
problems and it was using the means of
science and technology it's always felt
right
so my biggest inspiration to solve
problems was honestly it's just to help
someone in the world out there
in second grade i realized that i wanted
to combine my love of science with my
love of helping people so i entered a
lot of different challenges and i did
that for a couple of years before i
applied for the young scientist
challenge in 2017.
if you ask any of my family members or
friends i'm probably the most
competitive person you will ever meet
now but at the time i was scared of
applying something knowing that i would
lose
and what i've really done is realized
that if i don't try i'm going to lose
regardless
in the beginning of my final
presentation at the event i talked about
a little boy named openmeppo he's 10
years old and lives in flint michigan
and um the young scientist challenge
really set up a platform for me to
amplify my voice regarding
science and technology as well as all
these devices that i've worked towards
creating
so to date i've created about 10 or 11
innovations and three of them are ones
that i've created into fully functioning
prototypes and one of them has already
been released
i'm continuously solving problems that i
have a connection to
one of my favorite devices and the one
that garnered the most recognition after
the young scientist challenge is called
tetanus
imagine living day in and day out
drinking contaminated water with
dangerous substances like lead i heard
about the water crisis in flint michigan
and it was absolutely appalling to see
how many kids my age were essentially
drinking a poison every single day
and it has these carbon nanotube sensors
that are built into it that are exposed
to the water this is the interior of it
which is made up of a little
microcontroller as well as a whole
circuit which is essentially able to
measure resistance and that's what
identifies the lead is the higher the
lead the higher the resistance and it
sends all the data to your mobile phone
on an app that i created one of our
family friends ended up getting into a
car accident in which
when the doctor prescribed medications
he ended up becoming addicted to them
it was just so scary to see all of that
go down
first hand
this is epione which is a device that
helps to diagnose prescription opioid
addiction kindly is an anti-cyber
bullying service so basically it uses
the latest developments in artificial
intelligence machine learning natural
language understanding and processing to
pick out words or phrases that may be
considered bullying
[Music]
at one point i didn't think i wanted to
innovate anymore and the reason for that
is i was tired of being pushed over to
the side just because of the way i look
our generation is growing up in a place
where we're seeing problems that have
never existed before
and it's up to us to now realize that
innovation is not an option it's a
necessity
you know one girl cannot solve all of
the world's problems
and that's exactly why i'm hoping to
solicit new innovators into this world
of stem
all of us can make a difference it's
just about finding that one thing you
want to change and changing it
i want to use science to inspire
kindness
i cannot see a world filled with
positivity and kindness without science
involved
science is a force for good in the world
you can do so much with it but you can
also
really
find yourself with it and i think that
that's the beauty of science and
technology
[Applause]
i want to see a world where people are
not judged on their skin color or their
gender or how old they are
if you have the drive and passion and
motivation to create a difference in
society
nothing else matters
when i was in high school i got an
academic award
we're at the ceremony and i'm walking up
to get my award and my mom is sitting
there
and she says represent
and i as a kid had no idea what she
meant by that
[Music]
and
when i got to the stage you know and i'm
looking around
i was the only black person up there
oh
what she's saying is represent for the
community represent for black people
because you're the only one up there
that looks like you
oh
oh
my name is dr sierra sybils i'm a
nuclear engineer
you know never in a million years if you
would ask me back in high school if i
would have been a nuclear engineer i
would have said
hell no um take that out
i'm originally from chesapeake virginia
the school i went to was hickory high
school
it was kind of more predominantly white
my parents you know started to sit me
down and say okay look you're not like
the other people in your class you look
different people may make assumptions
about you based on the way that you look
and as a kid i didn't understand you
know what they were trying to tell me i
kind of saw them as being dramatic but
over time i started to realize okay
they're preparing me for the world as a
minority you're gonna have to work
harder
that's the first thing i ever made when
i went to mit and those people ate that
lasagna
and i didn't even like it because they
didn't have a stage
cooking is something that's really big
in my family and it's something that i
felt like i was good at it came natural
to me
and at the time you know being a chef
was the only thing that i really
considered for a career and something
that i was really passionate about and
never had any thoughts about doing
anything else
something that my parents pushed was
having really good grades and making
sure you did well in school i was good
at math and science but i never saw it
as an opportunity to have a career
and it wasn't until i took chemistry
that my love for science really started
to blossom
i was really interested in the atom the
periodic table how these elements come
together and create new things
in that chemistry class that really
sparked my interest um my teacher mr
harold he was the one to make that
connection between
chemistry and cooking and engineering
for me
and you said yeah i'll probably just go
to you know local college here or
culinary school i said sierra
you're one of my best chemistry students
and he said well you should look into
being a chemical engineer have you heard
of that do you know what they do and i
was like no and he was like go look it
up and come back and tell me what you
find
he was someone that challenged me he was
the first person to say why don't you
take an ap class he didn't have to do
that but he saw something to where he
was like i feel like i can impact her
career and that's what he did
and so i would bring him different
schools and he'll be like that's a good
school but i think you can apply someone
better and when i looked at mit i was
like oh man it's like six or eight
percent acceptance rate like i don't
think i'm ever going to get in there so
when i brought that to mr harold he was
like yeah this is the kind of school
that you should be applying to
i said carol you're the best i will be
sure to harass you next year and more
years to come
and you kept your word
[Laughter]
you can harass me anytime you want any
time you want
it was a classmate that said hey didn't
you apply to mit like um did you check
and see if you got in and i was like no
i'm gonna go to vcu he was like oh well
you should just check and so i went and
i checked and i got in and
they were like you got into mit because
of the demographics and that stuck with
me because i was like well what
what what is it that they're saying
about me what are they saying about the
institution
and and that kind of pushed me to go
because i was like okay well you guys
are mad that i got into mit so now i
really gotta go
mit was the first time i really
got challenged because that's the first
time i failed a class that's the first
time i was making like c's and d's
so i just remember you always calling
and being so upset and crying on the
phone because you got a b
at mit
and i'd be like you need to hang up and
call mom because i can't understand what
you're saying so
you didn't know that that was normal
for you to not get straight a's
especially somewhere like that
that's what i was used to doing so
yeah and it's not normal
so after mit i went on to the university
of michigan and got my phd in 2019. so i
was the first black woman to get a phd
in nuclear engineering
i struggled with the idea of being the
first because it was like yes i'm the
first i'm going to open this door up for
other people coming behind me but i also
was like why did it take so long how are
they still the first black woman to do x
i think part of it yes is systemic
racism we weren't even allowed to go to
an institution like mit
when i was presented with the
opportunity to go to a place like mit to
go to a place like michigan i saw that
as an opportunity to open the door for
people that look like me to come in and
be involved in this in these fields
and now i've arrived at johns hopkins
university applied physics lab where i'm
a nuclear engineer i focus more on
radiation simulations specifically
looking at how radiation affects
materials so when we irradiate something
how does that change the atom how does
it change its composition how does it
change its structure
when you look at rural communities or
small towns or or minority communities
there's an issue of access there's an
issue of exposure
things like social media are ways that
we can start to break down some of these
barriers
so at mit one of the things that came to
the forefront for me was that i was
passionate about teaching and this idea
of mentorship this idea of inspiring the
next generation
showing them that people that look like
them are out there in these fields
and we are trying to create a narrative
in a community to show the next
generation of stem leaders that hey this
is possible and it's fun
i tell kids that
anything is possible no
goal or dream is too small
each year we ask a student admitted to
mit to share with us the name of a
teacher who has been especially
influential in his or her development
it is a remarkable achievement and a
great honor to change a life so we
congratulate you on being named this
year by sierra b civils you do the work
from which all of society benefits
congratulations again on your excellent
work we at mit are deeply grateful
yeah and they're not lying you really
you change your life like
and i think that's the nice thing about
being a mentor because you encounter
kids very early on in their career
journey and especially young black girls
and you open their eyes
then they look at you and think oh if
she can do that i can do that
and my message to them is
yes you can
there's a stereotype of scientists
one that they're male and they're boring
they don't dress well and they're like
very awkward
[Music]
i'm obviously not that type
you know i'm a latina woman so i've got
that latina passion
i'm a person of faith
i sing
i dance
i love clothes
i'm not your typical scientist
and i always knew that being true to
myself being true to what drives me was
going to be the key to
a successful and satisfying career
[Music]
my name is dr jessica taff i'm a
microbiologist by training and i have
used my
phd in microbiology and my experience
studying infectious diseases like hiv
and malaria
to apply that in the world of global
health which is really important in
everybody's lives and i especially feel
this now with copid
i grew up in the united states
i was born here
my mom is paraguayan
the latin culture definitely plays into
who i am and how i grew up
there's just this love of life
and family is so important so important
to us
my dad's side he's your typical wasp i
guess you know caucasian he's a forester
you know that that played into my
childhood
in a way that you know we were out in
nature we always learned about science
both of them encouraged not just us
experience science but other subjects
like music and art
my mom has this funny story about me
she
says i always knew you were going to be
a scientist because you used to mix all
of my perfumes
i always had this interest in the
biology of infectious diseases but also
really wanted to be involved in global
health and applied my scientific
expertise my biomedical expertise in
that arena and the first roadblock was
having people understand
what type of career i wanted
because it was not your typical academic
career your typical research career i
couldn't really figure out how i was
going to
live at the intersection of that and
that was incredibly frustrating because
it was something that i wanted to do
another roblox was i felt like
i had to tone down my personality in
order to be respected
so for instance the first months that i
was doing my postdoc at the national
institutes of health i didn't wear my
red lipstick because i
didn't want people to focus on that and
then not take me seriously i wanted them
to focus on my science first i really
shouldn't have done that
but yeah because i didn't see a lot of
people like me
i felt like i had to fit in in the way
that just wasn't really authentic to who
i am
to do something that felt true to my
passion
and true to my professional mission
i had to find my community to help me
figure this out
i sought out you know what the global
health community was i found other
people
that understood the things that i was
excited about and passionate about i
also met other people like myself and
made friends with them and realized that
there's a lot of diversity in science
there's a lot of other people like me
i feel like throughout my career i've
grown i accept myself
and by not conforming by staying true to
myself to my culture to who i am this
gave me the confidence to pursue and
make a path to my own type of career
i knew that i could use my scientific
knowledge in the world of public health
to make a difference in people's lives
and then you know at some point people
started to notice that my points were
valid
so i left the lab
i did a bunch of
consulting and science in the global
health arena working for groups like the
world bank united nations which was
fantastic like that was definitely the
realm that i enjoy being in it just
clicks
you know you're doing what you're
supposed to be doing
[Music]
and that's what keeps me moving forward
when covet hit
this was this huge realization of like
this is what i have been preparing for
my entire life this is why science is
important to global health right here
right now so scientists swooped in
they went to sequence the virus to
better understand it now
a year later we've got people getting
vaccines like that's amazing scientists
have been heroes in this pandemic and
it's been so exciting to see that play
out everyone is going to remember this
moment in time they will remember having
lived through covid
i hope that the next generation of
scientists get inspired by this moment
and how important science is
[Music]
i'm a new mom i have this precious
little baby girl
i hope she grows up in a world where she
feels like she can do whatever she wants
[Music]
where
diversity
in expression and personality and
culture
all sorts of things is celebrated
appreciated tolerated and i'd love that
if she chose a career in science
she didn't feel stifled she felt like
she fit in and she
could
express her scientific self in whatever
way
she wanted
if you inspire a girl to go into a stem
career and show her the different ways
that she can do what she loves
she can change the world
[Music]
when i was growing up i never thought of
myself as the science and engineering
type because i wasn't breaking apart
toys curious to understand how they work
what i wondered about was the humans who
put them together what were they
thinking
to me it was always the human context
that was powerful
i knew from a young age i wanted to do
something that would solve problems help
people improve lives i just wanted to
make the world a better place and in
looking back i realized that i would
have never been a scientist or an
engineer had it not been for my parents
persistence to me the the humanities was
much more interesting and exciting
but now i know science is a human
endeavor and it's one in which you can
bring your whole self in
your ideas your inspiration your passion
your interests and that's exactly what i
did
3m and i'm also 3ms first ever chief
science advocate i do come from a family
that really values education my
great-grandfather had a master's i'm not
sure how many people can say that my
maternal grandfather was a physician my
father retired as the director of
india's national institute of hydrology
my mother is a college graduate i know
that we have a long legacy of education
and it was very important in the family
so as a young family my dad decided that
we would move to a place called roorkee
and it's just an engineering town
because there is this premier
engineering institute then there's the
irrigation research institute the army
corps of engineers
so it was just in the water we used to
joke that everybody just has to become
an engineer and what that meant is all
the parents encouraged their kids to
become engineers even their daughters so
i did well in school i always liked
working hard and it comes down to this
entrance exam
and i didn't get in
i didn't get in so i ended up in a
college thousands of miles away from
home
in a completely different part of the
country it's like going from ireland to
portugal it's a different language
different culture different social norms
it was a really big change for me
so i was in my final year and everybody
was applying to go to the us for
graduate school
and just in competition with the guys
you know i also applied
and this time
i got in
and so long story short i ended up in
the us at clarkson university in upstate
new york for my master's in chemical
engineering and in many ways when i look
back i realized that i became a trained
blazer because i was the only girl in
the lab there were 14 of us and i was
working on a theoretical modeling
project
and i would look around and there were
other people in the lab who were
actually doing experiments all these
years sort of i never realized what is
it that i wanted see i was kind of going
along with what the expectations were
off me for the first time i started
realizing the sense of
is this what i want to do what is it
that i like and i realized that i wanted
to do experiments i wanted to feel that
whatever i was doing was helping people
in looking back i feel like i was
missing the human context of what i was
doing so i decided to switch from my
masters to my phd my fields i have to
start over but somewhere deep down i
also knew that
i have done this before i have
reinvented myself many times already and
have done new things i'll be fine
so i had the opportunity to do an
internship at 3m
and that's when i first came to
minnesota and i thought it was a great
environment and and i got offered a
full-time position it was in a
completely different area than my
master's or phd so my phd was in
diamond-like films and i came here and i
started working on closures and
fasteners for disposable diapers so i
always joke that i went from diamonds to
diapers i'd never seen a diamond i'd
never seen a diaper so what's the
difference
i would envision
what it would be like for a child to
wear these diapers you know and and we
made them softer and softer from our
closures
and just that context
and the empathy that you feel for the
end user was such a critical part of the
science that i was doing and that was so
important to me
so i was very successful in some of my
early projects i got a lot of accolades
i started getting noticed i got more and
more challenging projects and with each
one it sort of built my confidence
so i've had a successful career i've
been here 27 years i have worked on many
different product innovations i'm at the
highest level a scientist can attain
[Music]
with my role as the chief science
advocate i got the opportunity to
observe people's perception of science
and the relationship society has with
science
it was very interesting 4 out of 10 said
if science didn't exist
their lives would be no different
this was shocking
science is all around us it has made our
lives so much better but we haven't
communicated it for the average public
to understand and so the more
stereotypes we break the better outcomes
we're going to have because we invite
more people into the world of science
so this is my office and yes
the patents are
part of the projects that i worked on
for over 27 years that i've been at 3m
and i don't know if i can say there is a
special or favorite patent it's really
not about the patents it's about the
problems we solve and each of these
patents reminds me of the people that i
have collaborated with to solve those
problems so these are
all very special to me
i never thought of myself as the science
type but it turns out i am the science
type
i want to tell the next generation of
stem students that you don't have to be
what people expect from a scientist some
outdated stereotype as far as racial and
gender equity goes we need every idea
every diverse perspective in order to
solve problems in fact that's exactly
what we need more of science needs you
to be you
[Music]
[Applause]
i think it's gonna be okay
no city to keep me awake
[Music]
it's gonna be
okay cause it's a good day when i know
who i am who i was
[Music]
do whatever
[Music]
we will be
[Music]
we will be tameless
[Music]
[Music]
do
[Music]
[Music]
so
[Music]
four very inspiring stories we just saw
in that movie i got a little bit of
goosebumps actually so it made me kind
of feel good how about you guys do you
feel good with that yeah so very
inspirational and um
now we want to talk about those career
paths into science because it's it's a
we all know that the media is full of it
it's a very male dominated area and
especially for women it's hard to get in
there and so i'm very happy and lucky to
have three scientists here three female
scientists here on my panel to discuss
this
issue and they are going to share their
experience with us um about their career
path so first of all i want to welcome
fanny fanshawn berg also her interests
were actually more into stem fields you
started uh studying business
administrations yes then so it made a
i think the doubts came over you and you
said okay i go back to the stem area and
now currently you're studying natural
science in the information society at
the t u berlin
and you're really also ambassador for
other young ladies to say hey okay let's
go there let's do it don't doubt it
don't go to business administration do
science it was great i mean it was great
i loved it but i knew that i wanted to
do more
yeah
to the right side is
dr emily fritz she's a chemist and since
completing her doctorate eight years ago
she has been working as a product
developer at 3m in noise that's in
western germany near dusseldorf
and there she's developing product
solutions for batteries in electric cars
and i have a quote
i got a quote from you i'm certainly not
going to save the world but i can do my
part to improve electric cars and thus
be part of this exciting change in the
industry and ultimately in people's life
yeah so uh you're not heading for the
big big big picture and saying okay i'm
going to change i would make the big
invention
but you're the part of it yeah i mean
who knows i mean my career is not over
but it's not that i'm
i don't have to do it right i mean it's
um
i'm not at the university i'm not doing
research but i do want i want to do
something and i i found my place where i
think you know i can do something so
that's the start that sounds great
and on the right hand side amelie reigel
a.k.a the scientist division
i think if i would ask like 100 people
to
paint me a picture of a scientist no
picture of you would come up because
you're an influencer in scientific
issues you're on instagram and tick tock
you have more than
thousand followers on tv
360 000. yeah i know it's very important
for influencer okay so i think it was
like last time i checked this was 300 so
overnight it was 40 000 more right yeah
yeah
tomorrow it's going to be more um you
really understand how to to take those
those complex uh topics and and really
comprehend them and also in a very
entertaining way i have to say and
actually actually you're doing your
doctorate at the university of wurzburg
at the chair of tissue engineering and
this is what i totally obsessed about
starting your day with a handstand yes
yes i like why do you do that i mean
every day you see a picture of you doing
in handstand honestly yes i like doing
uh new things and handstand i thought
okay why not and now i'm trying and
trying to get a longer handstand yeah
okay it's fun
we try that later okay yeah okay in the
end we both try i try to do a handstand
and you can do an answer all right okay
i mean if we are well i'm going to be
the entertaining part who you can join
no
emily i wanted to start um we just heard
about the stereotypes here in the movie
in the last part of the movie and
whenever there's a picture of scientists
for example in pop culture in media it's
always this kind of i mentioned sheldon
cooper this nerdy anti-social guy
highly intelligent doing stuff that
nobody understands i'm asking straight
away how much of a shell and cooper are
you
well
this took too long that took too long i
mean i would say
i'm definitely a nerd right i mean in a
way i'm passionate if being a nerd is
being passionate about something right
then i'm a nerd yeah
um me too yes yeah of course but
but being that one that that doing
things alone or you're not
talking to people it doesn't have to be
like that and and
a lot of the time it's the other way
around you're not going to get things
done
alone most people won't
you need a team and then you need to be
able to to
work with people but in your opinion why
is this misleading picture
always be found everywhere
i mean it's i mean
it starts i mean you mentioned him
alberta einstein right i mean you have
these great people in history and and
most of the time is men
and it is that man in front of a very
nice oak tree desk and that's how we
think a scientist is or
sitting in the lab right um
yeah that's how i if i'm thinking about
it myself that's how i picture a
scientist too although i am a scientist
right so
so we have we have young people watching
us while live stream and also in the
audience maybe they think about
heading for a career into science
maybe you can just give us an impression
what does your typical day look like at
3 am
oh
that varies and we start from the moment
you get up i get up uh well i need to i
start my day with a coffee so that's
that's that's a common start you have
kind of ai there doing that for you or
is it
at least alexa or something no um no but
it's um
3m it's it's
it's
yes a lot of things are are the same
right you have a topic you have a
project you need to solve an issue
but but it's not a straight way it's
always like
new things coming up new challenges that
you need to to
kind of solve so
it's varying it is
it is talking to people yes it is also
data analysis you need to be able to to
present your
data in a good way right but so it's
also this yes you sit in front of the
computer
but there's also meetings you have to
talk to that process engineer you need
to
be at the maker where you're producing
things and and it's everything and then
it's also
sitting in front of people presenting to
my management yeah so it is it's
everything from being getting your hands
dirty to
doing nice presentations would you say
if you think of your develop team are
you are you kind of
i don't know working in a bubble or is
it more that you meet all different kind
of people in your everyday work no it's
it's very cross-functional uh and and
that's that's kind of what keeps me
going i have to say in my position as a
product developer that um
i kind of feel like i'm in the middle of
it all
because
you have to you're there from the
beginning
of an idea yeah a customer
have have an issue they have something
that you need to solve
you come up with ideas you work with the
research department within 3m that have
the technologies and then we kind of
bring them together into products right
and then
it is talking to business people it is
talking to manufacturing people so it's
no it's a lot of time is more
talking to other people making sure that
you're talking asking the right
questions and which part do you love
most
the
talking to people the talking to people
part no but making those connections um
and and
this feeling of when when your team is
actually accomplishing something right
and knowing that hey i was part of that
and and i made that connection um
between two people
you might not have all the answers
yourself and making those connections uh
yeah making connection is a good
transition
to amelie so don't get confused we have
emily and we have amelie a little bit
confusing i know but uh amelie as a as
an influencer on social media i mean
basically you're a scientist you're
doing your doctorate and you're going to
the lab and you're doing i think you're
doing on on artificial skin stuff like
that so tissue engineering is maybe you
can describe first what would you what
your actual work is
um i growing human skin as 3d test
system to reduce animal experiments and
that's what i do in the lab and
after this or um before i go into the
lab in the morning i'm doing science
communication to um yeah tell the people
how cool is science
why do you do that i mean how did you
come up with that idea um yeah i'm a
nerd too
and i love science i think it's it's
crazy how beautiful it is and
how cool and i was like okay i have to
tell somebody and i told it every my
friends and
then there was the pandemic with kovit
and
i was like okay nobody is talking about
what is happening what is the virus why
do we have to wear masks and i was like
okay nobody does so i i just do it and
then i started tick tock and uh yeah the
the people wanted to hear something and
wanted to to communicate and want to see
what is it to be a scientist and then i
started okay i
just
show you what it looks like and it looks
like this or that or that and yeah i'm
doing a handstand and i show it to my
community as well i as i am standing in
the lab and doing my uh research and i
think this is
important to see what it's what is it
looks like to be a scientist
yeah and social media it's a lot about
interaction with your audience um what
kind of people are these people
following you who is this this kind of
are those also scientists or are they
more kind of of average people being
interested into science yes um i want
you to make science mainstream so
everybody who wants to learn something
about it i want to explain it as simple
as possible and i have young people who
say wow i didn't know this is a job i
want to do it how can i do it and
i have also um colleagues and other
scientists who say oh that's great i
want to talk and i want to
show my
experience and
my
research but i don't know how and yeah
that's
the communication but for out of my
experience i'm working as a tv
journalist also in science doing
scientific reports and stuff every time
i'm going to ask a professor or a
scientist for for having an interview
and it takes some time it's always a
little bit of pain in the ass to be
honest because we come there and we put
up lights and it's taking hours and they
don't have the time i completely
understand it but many of them are like
yeah i i don't really want to do this
kind of of publicity stuff um why
do you meet people like that so are
there also people who don't understand
what you are doing there why are you on
tick tock yes yes of course because um
for a scientist you have to to tell
facts and to be clear and if you have
something complex you have to describe
it with
complex um words and on tech talk or
social media you can't do this you have
to be simple and that's the problem to
be simple but correct and
as a scientist you don't speak simple
you have to talk in this language i say
and and i think that's the problem or
the challenge i i had those those cases
because then i asked them could you
break this down a little bit because
it's very common yeah and then they were
like yeah i can't do that because my
colleagues are
going to to be upset about it yeah but
it's not about your colleagues my
audience actually
so how do you find that that special
tone how do you do that
um my friends told me every time i
talked about my research project and
they are not all scientists or
biologists they are engineers or
something like this okay emily nice and
can you talk um can you explain it now
to me with simple words i didn't
understand anything the last 15 minutes
and i was like okay huh i have to change
something and then i started to
to break it down to to speak um yeah
with a similar language and
i think it was fun and so i i thought
yeah okay i'm doing it on tech talk and
do you also find yourself confronted
with stereotypes or are you playing with
stereotypes on your channel
yes a little bit and
i think it's it's a little bit
confusing in the biology
studio there are more female persons
and
if you are going higher in the master
and phd
there are less and less
and
then i i was thinking why what's
happening and if i um
see my boss or higher positions they're
less and less women and so i was
thinking
why what what's happening yeah but but
what how do you experience that how do
you what does it do with you what do you
feel inside if you if you see okay all
my bosses are why did you cho cho why
have you chosen this path anyway because
you saw that there are many men and and
in higher positions do you want to go
there do you want to achieve a higher
position what is your your long long
term game yes i want to achieve a higher
position
because i want to do my own research
project i started it after my bachelor
thesis and
i just want to do this the next 40 years
and i know this that's not possible in
the german uh
science because you you have to
um
yeah bring your own money or you get the
money and stuff like this and that's why
i want a higher position to do my own
research and not something else research
okay let's come to the lady
right on my right side here
fanny
we have a scientist over there speaking
in front of a camera we have a scientist
actively working at a big innovative
company like 3m um now we got you you're
still studying in the most students most
exciting city of the world berlin do you
have any time for studying actually yes
yeah okay cool but actually i do that
you know i actually study
yeah um and
so
i sometimes when people say i don't know
i study humanities or philosophy or
something like that people are like oh
what are you going to do with that one
yes i actually care about studying i
have to repeat it get natural science in
the information society yes
i mean it's a personal question but if
you go on a date and you tell somebody
like that what what are the reactions i
actually get that question quite a lot
um
i always tell yeah i do like science and
then they were like
what
like biology or stuff like that and like
you know like science like everything
um
yeah it's actually an inside joke
in my course because we all have to do
that
and funny story actually was at the
hairdresser like two weeks ago and she
did my hair amazingly like
and she asked me what i do and i was
like yeah i'm studying signs and she was
like oh so you draw like the leaves on
the trees and i was like what
no
i'm not doing that and i was thinking
she would like saying oh you're always
like in front of your computer or
something like that but no she was
thinking i was drawing trees and i was
like no i mean you can do that and then
she asked me what i would do in the
future like what i would be working and
i was like hmm i mean i can do so many
things
and she was like yeah but you can only
be a teacher right and i was like no i
mean i can i mean if i want to it's a
great
compassion to do so but i was like it's
research you know how big research is
and
i always have to tell them and
even somebody told me that i would be a
taxi driver
because there's nothing i can do with it
with my degree
and i was furious i'm always furious
because i can do so much more
and yeah it's an open field i mean we
can see that and these are just two
people and i'm i mean i'm not sure what
i want to do
and that's probably because
many people think that i end up i don't
know being a taxi driver
and i'm like
what do you what do you actually plan to
to become
where where's your well
my compassion actually is astrophysics
okay um i love the stars i mean i would
love to be an astronaut but i'm really
seasick or like sick and every like
driving
thing
yeah i puked on everything so
i mean
maybe there's a future for me and that
field
yeah but i would love to do research in
that but i'm also very into chemistry
yeah or like data science
um
yeah machine learning
um
yeah
but what i'm totally interested in
because you started with business
administration why did you do that i
mean you were always passionate about
about about the stem field about
becoming an astronaut and everything why
did you go into business administration
i mean i don't wanna
touch the business administration if
anybody here is in business
administration is totally fine yeah it's
great yeah cool to have you guys
pushing numbers around
but why did you do that well i'm truly
honest with you i really thought i would
be too stupid
i thought i was not capable of doing
like all the mathematics and like
studying so hard and
every time i was like the convention or
something and i asked the people and it
was like yeah it's so hard and was like
oh my god i don't want to do it
i will fail and so where did that come
from that feature i'm not sure
um
i was just i mean in school i loved
science and i'm very thankful to my
teacher in ninth grade so i was very
emotional doing that movie because i
felt that
and then you're not sure
i think it was just myself being stupid
over that not being stupid
but then
after that one year i learned that i
like it i like economics
but i wanted to do more into like
scientific area so i went to like the
student advisement department
at the te u berlin
and i asked them that like i have no
idea but i want to change something and
they told me like here go to mint green
and
fall of umid green is like an
orientation course at the to berlin it's
for one year so mint yeah the
equivalent yeah
german
and that's actually where i work now at
an advisor and i do that what um the
person to me did i like i advise helping
you oh come on really yeah now you give
your experience to other students who
come there and say i have no idea
yes that's actually what i do now
because i know how you feel like being
lost and not knowing what you should do
or not do but how does it work actually
so you go there and this is just one
year i think yeah it's just one year and
we always tell just do whatever you want
to do it's not for like finding out what
you want to do it's actually the
opposite like find what you do not want
to do even if you don't want to study i
mean i always say yeah i'm from the
scientific area but you don't have to do
that i mean it's great but there are so
many other great options out there
and
yeah so that's what i do
i help
people finding out what they don't want
to do so for all the people who have no
idea how how has
the studies of a scientific field looks
like
for example when i think of my time
studying there were days i was glad when
i put my pants on
during the day because of studying so
this is also a part of something so
there's also this lazy time it doesn't
exist right okay cool typically but how
does it how does a typical day look like
when you when you're into science well
it depends what courses i take um
if i have laboratory time then it's like
a long day or long week because we have
to prepare like really hard because we
have to
like present our ideas what we want to
do in front of the professors
and we have to tell them that we don't
screw up
and don't burn everything or destroy i
mean it
um there's happened
reason for it yeah yeah it's expensive
you know
and yeah then
i start my day with tea actually not
coffee
no no handstand and
then i walk my dog
and then i go to uni
and normally i have learn groups
so we're studying there together because
like she said
scientific area of research is like
teamwork and that's very very important
to me because
um i learned during business
administration that there was like
more like a competitive
like vibe going on there and that's what
i love in the scientific area because
you can't do anything alone we're not
like a hundred years ago where you work
okay how's it changing in a company
later on or if you're going for a
doctorate is there is there a lot of
competition in in scientific education
and scientific jobs
no about
i can only agree i mean from from my
doctorates it's it's a
it kind of becomes a family you're yes
you have your own uh
project and everyone is like you have to
deliver on on on your project right to
get your doctorate in the end of the day
but
you do it together with people and
you're supporting and you're learning
from each other so
and then at
work
no i mean i
well can speak for everywhere right but
my experience so far i've
no there's not this type of competition
it is
um of course we all want to proceed in
our careers but
most people realize you will do that by
working with others and with others
succeed and the team succeeds you
succeed right so so whatever you put in
to the team you will get back eventually
so
yeah i i don't see it so that much
competition yeah i agree with you i
think teamwork is uh so important
because science is getting so complex
and you can do everything you have to
do to work with mathematics or physics
or chemistry um to bring your project
forward okay so maybe we sum up uh for
the first part for you guys at home
watching us live stream so
education and working in science it's
more about teamwork it's not the lone
stranger thing we see on television it's
not the
anti-social nerdy thing it's about
talking to people it's about going uh
passionate into those topics and um it's
also
quite a lot of fun actually but i want
to go back to the point where you had
those stouts in your school career but
we saw the teacher in the movie and he
was like yeah you're my best students
and i'm going to help you to get a good
university and she ended up at mit
did you have similar experiences in your
career path maybe in school or later on
yeah in in school i was really good in
biology and so i thought okay that's the
thing i i will do this
and so it was quite easy for me to
um go in this direction i want to do
medicine but i was too bad so i thought
now biology maybe and then i realized
wow that's it this i wanted to do i
didn't want to work with
patients i i want to stand in the lab
sometimes at night alone and just do my
experiments and everything is good and
yeah
okay um but but
how did you overcome this this this
moment you said okay i want to go into
medicine
the marks aren't good enough then i went
to biology but were there any barriers
or borders where you said okay
like like
male competitors or something where you
said okay i don't get i don't get the
point no not really not in biology
because there are many uh women in
biology
to study biology and then when you get
higher and higher
so you were perfectly fine with your
school career everything was cool in
school yes okay
with you emily oh i was a uh
a student you know i had really good
grades and and
i
liked basically everything um
worked hard um
and and for me it was actually um
the
when i decided to go for chemistry uh i
went to to a good
high school so everyone was very
ambitious and that was the first time i
was challenged because before that i was
more
it was one of the best in the class
right and and
being with others they were
passionate about but learning things
that was kind of what triggered my
you know that i wanted to continue to
study um
but i applied for university
in gothenburg i'm from sweden um
chemistry and i was like oh my god oh my
god will i get in when i get in and
realize that everyone
this this is true this is the truth
everyone that applied got in and i was
like
what
okay so you made it to bury up in your
own house yeah because
for business administration though
you needed good grades yeah right i mean
i had that for that and and and made for
medicine
but but that was so
it was a little bit sad to realize that
huh
because the grades then is kind of you
need to have a certain level right but
knowing that
not enough people
for this in sweden applied for chemistry
i was like this is so sad i mean this is
so cool and then no one is
but but also kind of lucky for you
because yeah sure you don't have to
go through that struggle like others and
uh being denied at the university well i
was denied later on when for my master
so i have been
denied entry into university so i know
how that feels too
but but yeah
but uh i want to talk numbers actually
because it's quite interesting 3m had a
study and
i read it and
it says that 83
of germans say we need to encourage
girls for stem education even 84 believe
we need more people to pursue uh stem
careers
and now it's a funny fact is but only
eight percent of the younger people say
i see myself in such a career it's it's
kind of like the climate crisis
everybody is like yeah probably we
should do something about it about it
but maybe some someone else should do it
how does that come in your opinion
well i can see that every day because
it's my job to actually talk about that
and my boss is actually happy
if we have more than 30 percent of the
new students are like women
and i'm like 30 i mean that's so sad i
mean just 30
and then we get like a yay oh my god
we're so good we have so many women
and i'm sad because i can see that every
day during my courses through my student
experience
i'm always the most of the time the only
woman in class or maybe they're like two
or three
and yeah sometimes yeah i would love to
have like more women around me okay yeah
another big topic if you're talking
about the career path into science um
you just mentioned the orientation
course and you're now an advisor for
other students so congratulations this
is really cool um another thing is
mentoring did you have a mentor on your
way anybody of you
yeah yeah how was how did you find that
person or maybe you maybe can just give
a short explanation what a mentor is
and uh how did you find that person for
me a mentor is a
person who
yeah it's right next to you and and work
with you just a career path
but is older or wiser and
can
give you advice
if you are working and
i have this and i think that's the
it's important to um
yeah be a scientist to to have somebody
who who says okay this is the science
world
that because i was there and i thought
okay everybody likes everybody and we do
science and for the world and everything
is good and now this isn't it's it's
about money to get to do your project or
stuff like this and you have to to look
how can you do your project and yeah my
mentor is um
great because he he tells me what i have
to to listen and and what uh can i do
and what are my
options what what can i do i just don't
have to to go the academic way something
like this i can do this and this and
that and i think this is very important
to have a good mentor who says
at the early beginning of the career
yeah what
can be possible
and
how do you do that you go there and say
hey you seem nice and you seem to have a
lot of experience you want to be my
mentor
no
it was developing i did
a scholarship in different institutes
and i know at the first day of my
studium i wanted to do tissue
engineering but i wanted to see
everything else to
be
safe and knowing i don't want to do this
or that and
then i got to another institute and i
found him and it was like he explained
and he said
more than he had to something like this
and
i
could ask him everything about the
career the signs
how is it to go to conferences he pushed
me to do talks and
something
i was a little bit afraid of and he said
you have to just try it you can do it
and i think this motivation
is yeah
very important
how about you emily did you have a
mentor or maybe you are already a mentor
for somebody else um
so um
at 3am now i i have
and and 3m is supporting that and they
do see that there is a benefit
for for having mentors um
and i had i was also in the program at
university uh well during my phd but
before that i didn't have a mentor and i
think that's something
perhaps i would say
we should do a little bit more of i mean
just to have someone to to have that
exchange with you with ideas right where
you want to go
um
but
looking at it back in i mean perhaps one
of my teachers were kind of my mentor my
chemistry teacher at high school she was
very
she was listening and pushing and
challenging right i mean it is
nothing official but it's it's a type of
mentorship i would say so okay yeah
um we saw in the movie that woman she
came out of this
total scientific family so everybody
from the aunt to father and the brother
sisters everybody was
scientific so she had a big motivation
to go in that kind of field but many
people don't come from families like
that you were just talking about
motivation um
what do you think where do we where can
young people get this motivation from if
they if they are interested in that i
mean i have a four-year-old daughter and
she's totally interested in everything
she uses all kinds of liquids and then
she mixes it and since that i'm
interested in cleaning tissues and stuff
like that but
but but
somewhere in the system there must be a
point where we excuse me if i say so
where we [ __ ] up
because
because they lose this this interest um
so how do you keep up this interest how
do you get this motivation what is your
advice for for young people
listening now and saying hey
i'm interested in this but
it's difficult
oh it's a hard question i mean yes why
come on
you need to provide the answers and
i think it's quite easy for me to keep
this passion i want you to go to the lab
to do my research to to know what what
is it and then
i think this passion everybody has it
maybe where did you get it from i mean
did you have family or who who gave it
to it's inside it's inside yeah yeah
it's inside but you have to push it
sometimes or somebody else have to push
it in you so if we're talking about
about
few women in in science that maybe we
have a passion problem not a not an
education problem
no
no i mean if
i i think it's more
i i'm thinking a little bit about how i
was treated in school right i told you i
was good in school
but it was also supposed to be not quiet
we had the people in school that were
the the kids were they were a little bit
louder and took up a lot of the time
from from
um
from the class and the teachers uh and
and i
they didn't invest that much in me due
to the fact that others were not um
so i think
you said someone needs to
you need to be challenged and for me i
think it was also
i was treated bad once i mean i still
remember it it was a teacher who told me
we had a class it was kind of i don't
know
physics kind of
and i got the same grade i
was there i did all the experiments
which i thought was really fun
um
scored on my on my test and then there
was a guy
that barely was there
he was just there and didn't do anything
we got the same grade and the teacher
told me do you remember his name
the guy yeah yeah yeah what was the name
joel joel screw you yeah
it's not his fault because then the
teacher what was the teacher's name the
teacher uh him i forgot okay him i
forgot yeah yeah
no but he told me he told me well you're
pretty good for a girl
and i mean i'm not that old and and that
was really like i'm very competitive
right and i got that was the first time
when i realized okay
i might be a white woman but but there's
things that are not right here talking
about gender behavior i i made a note
here uh speaking up for yourself in my
experience for example as a journalist
if i call an expert
if it's a male expert i'm going to call
there and i'm like yeah we're covering
this kind of story um i need an expert
on this and kind topic and she's like
yeah not exactly my kind of fear of
research but what do you need intro yeah
no problem i can tell you that and i'm
like yeah if i talk to a female expert
and i'm like yeah and she's totally
straight and saying in in 90 of the time
she's like sorry not my field
can answer you so um
that's why i made this note about gender
behavior and speak up for yourself did
you have to learn in your business to to
to stand up uh to speak up for yourself
and say
i i have this expertise and i i can do
it because
men seem to be very
very easy
there's a difference i mean i have to
say sometimes i have to push myself i
have a a certain
rule to myself where i when people ask
you would you like to do this do you
really would you like to work on this i
say yes and sometimes i'm like oh [ __ ]
like i mean the first time i did like
some something standing in front of
people and talking and that's not my
daily job right and and and i was like
oh my god what have i done i will not
survive this but it's like pushing my
own
limits so i have to yeah and then and i
think we have to be just a little bit
self aware and if you're aware and i
know that sometimes i'm not the first
one to raise my hand and stuff like this
but
i'm trying so i have to challenge myself
a little bit so
yeah i i'm i'm still learning okay
what's your what's your advice i mean
you you're you have 360 000 followers on
tick tock
you're going out there every day showing
your face telling the people stuff and i
think you get a lot also maybe maybe
negative feedback or stuff how where do
you get your your
self-assurance
yeah i was
not so confident as well as i was
younger and i didn't talk much to people
and stuff like this and then there was a
switch um to i can talk about science
and now i i can talk and and i can
do this and i get more and more
confidence as well as in the social
media and now i'm talking with
yeah
important person from 3m or something
like this and it's yeah i can do this
i'm kind of confident enough because
i can this and and i show it every
time every day on social media stuff
like this and in the lab it's the same i
doing my experiments i know what i am
doing
sometimes better than my professor
and
because it's it's my project and i have
to think about it and i have to bring it
up and so i have to push uh myself and
yeah that's i think confidence is quite
important so so confidence doesn't just
fall from the sky you want to say it it
grew with with learning your profession
with studying your profession and and it
grows constantly yeah so everybody out
there if you don't if you have a lack of
confidence maybe or something listen to
that it's going to grow it's going to
come with every step um final round
please complete the sentence with one
sentence emily sign makes
science makes
people's lives better
cool
family if i hadn't become an influencer
for science would i have
oh i didn't get it yeah what would you
have done if you wouldn't have become oh
yeah scientist
sorry boring
funny what i enjoy most about my studies
[Music]
enjoy learning you enjoy learning yeah
that's like learning more like learning
things and like achieve more and just
yeah learn stuff just knowing yeah
that's very cool i mean i like that you
like learning and now i want to open for
the audience are there any questions for
our three female scientists here on our
panel
questions
so many questions
i think we answered everything they
wanted to know oh there's one actually
where yeah over there yeah please
hi great great hearing from you so which
advice would you give yourself right
maybe 10 years ago 20 years ago maybe
not so much
oh that's a good one
but what advice would you give yourself
when you were in doubt now looking back
what would you have done differently
well i can tell for myself just do it
just like the woman in the movie
said really it's that easy just try it i
mean
if you're thinking about losing then
that's not the right way to do it
yeah i agree with you
no no no no you have to find your own
that's mine
yeah keep your passion and just doing do
it and you
you have to challenge you then you can
grow
and and then i can maybe say
it is okay if you don't have a passion
in the beginning because i i was a
little bit
where do you want to go
i don't know i will just choose
something that i like that i think is
has a broad thing you will find your
passion it is so
don't be afraid if you don't have it
right now it will come for me this
sounds like a really perfect ending for
this panel if there are
aren't any questions anymore okay we
have still have some questions
thank you so much for sharing and the
movie was great and your life
are amazing i was wondering how has it
been with your family for example being
an influencer i know your mom what does
she say or i know your
your friends or you being in 3m no like
working on an enterprise when you're
you are studying chemistry no oh for you
being like right now so interested for
your family how has it been and and how
do you feel when you talk to your
parents or or
your family general
yeah i would say they are proud and
they like
that i am so
yeah
have found
this thing i want you to do my whole
life
and and and i would say the same my my
parents have been
also a driver uh my parents do not have
university background
my mom was the one who told me don't do
business so she's working she's a
controller so she's maybe one of the
reasons why i did science uh to be
honest so thanks mom um
but but i do see that they're proud and
they're they're
they're seeing that i am doing what they
would like to have done so yeah
well yeah my dad's a pilot and my mother
was a teacher
so i think
i don't know i always had like a way
into like some scientific fields um yeah
but i do think they're proud of me of
doing something but i think that's what
parents should do actually
so
yeah thanks mom and dad
[Music]
[Laughter]
yeah
all right any more questions over there
uh thank you so much for the very moving
video in the beginning and then
inspiring talks from all the ladies my
question is to emily i hope i'm saying
the right name
the influencer yeah so um
now to connect society with science we
need to create more content that is very
close to everyone especially the young
minds and everyone across society
actually
um i my question is how can we encourage
more young minds to become
science content creators and influencers
what are the things that you wish were
made easier for you or have been
available for you to start this journey
earlier or to support you more in this
journey and how can how do you think we
can encourage more to become influencers
in science thank you
thanks for this question i think um to
make science visible is the point and to
just show how it is to be a scientist
and and to do the
day as a scientist and to communicate
with the community and the followers
many of
the community or science community
is growing and i see it and we're
talking to each other and pushing and
mentoring or challenging challenging us
together so i think
to
yeah talk about it to to make it visible
to see scientists on tick tock on social
media next to
fashion or art or
something else i think this is important
to just see and talk about it
and also maybe not to take yourself too
seriously yes of course
yeah because sometimes if you look at
scientific youtube channels or something
i like that stuff but many people are
taking themselves too seriously yeah
in a fantastic way because there's
always this twinkle with the eye a
little bit like yeah this is not a
little bit of irony and everything so
it's also very important i guess yeah
everybody satisfied no more questions
then i would like to say thank you all
of you thanks for sharing your stories
your experiences all the best for your
further path into science and if you got
interested guys um watching our live
feed here and maybe you also are
interested into a scientific career go
for it just do it we just heard it just
go there don't think just jump do it now
go to the computer enlist yourself
somewhere for scientific studies or
something or maybe go to the next
chemistry course in your school and say
i want to do a project with my best
buddy or something do it do it do it
i say uh
big thanks to 3m for
providing this panel here today and
making this possible and
give a big hand for
our guest here on the panel have a good
way home enjoy berlin enjoy the rest of
the berlin science week
goodbye at home
[Music]
you